hey guys welcome to on live stream
my name is surah and I'm Heather and
we're so glad you joined us today um
we're gonna be answering all your
deepest darkest flight attendants dan
yeah presenting flight attendants
everywhere let him know who they're
talking to Heather tell me about
yourself so my name is Heather I'm from
Rock Hill South Carolina and I became a
flight attendant two years ago moved
from South Carolina to the Big Apple
haven't looked back off chakalaka is
that I'll point out in that next time it
does like a small I think she means self
she's a southern girl at heart Thomas
also from the South South Korea uh yo I
am um I'm a little asian baby that was
adopted in eighties so here I am
yeah I be I came my first flight ever
was actually to America and um who knew
now I'm a flight attendant I think I'm a
flight attendant just so I can find my
Korean parents if you're watching let me
know hit me up in the comments uh
parents and I'm just kidding um but yeah
guys send us your questions we're super
stoked to answer all of them where are
you guys from write it in the comments
or right now right now are you from
where you from oh shoot hello wait guys
we're asking a question here well you
from you're from yeah froz okay and I'm
curious hard to you what ages everyone
is yeah talking with you anyone's a
flight attendant your flight attendant
put an F a let me know ya know go to a
cafe or something true it's true we'll
eat at LaGuardia JFK preferably JFK
JFK's more preferable than yeah I would
run get JFK the best then Newark and
then LaGuardia for food personally all
right so let's check out some of y'all
burning questions alright so how old
were you when you were on an airplane so
I was 13 years old
and it was the best time of my life I
went to the Bahamas and when you're like
that age like you know what's going on
but you don't always know everything
that's going on my head was in the
clouds and I was like this is where I
belong I'm a Pisces looking out the
window at the wings taking my typical
flight attendant picture yeah I mean no
is gonna be a flight attendant here we
are
oh that's so cute what about you I was
um 13 months I don't remember a thing so
I think it went pretty well and that's
when I knew I wanted to be a flight
attendant not just kidding I didn't even
know what was going on um we have a
question we have a question from Elise
of the word f meow can you like just
live on an airplane i we can like just
yeah we can actually like but if you
have everything you need
um we got snacks we got in-flight
entertainment we got water we got meal
flights so Lincoln no I can check and
see on your flight benefits if that is a
meal flight and if you're hungry and the
bank is looking a little low you'll bank
I think actually you could go on the
hallways I think you could survive on an
airplane for PI like at least the week
or two with all the snacks and water
that are on there I mean you might worry
yeah you'd actually probably build your
immune system from all things on the
plane oh yeah oh here we got another one
Avery I quit how many times a day do you
have to be on a plane and is there a
limit
so we're depends on what you're
scheduled you can be scheduled two legs
or four legs so legs for flight
attendants or trips you go from
LaGuardia to Boston and Boston back to
LaGuardia that's too good but if you're
doing something like LaGuardia to Boston
to indeed to Dallas like that could be
four legs mm-hmm and as far as the limit
how many times do we have to be on a
plane well if you want to keep your job
you got to be on for the hold one my
tongue yeah but it's up to 16 hours of
duty time that's not what it is and
whenever your time not that's whenever
they are like all right yeah put you
back and we'll put you in the hotel but
they can limit your rest to 8:00
or depending on the airline just for the
ones that means yeah eight hour
oh gosh nah gee how often are the
airplanes actually fully cleaned toilets
alright hmm well there are usually
cleaned before between each flight
sometimes cleaning may just involve
crossing a seatbelt but they're fully
clean there's like an army of people
that come on the plane during some long
sits and they do the digging somewhere
overnight or if you're get that plane
depending on the co-chair is in one of
its home bases so they'll do usually a
full clean there but yeah and it comes
to cleaning the back of the seat of the
tables
yeah those don't get crazy - yeah I even
do it this toilets there more often than
yeah I still I still align that I still
wiped the toilet down and then I line
the toilet and then sometimes I still
squat so you just might want to like
have all your precautionary touch
anything grab some of the now no such
door knob touch the door honey when
we're working I know I take the sprays
and any hand sanitizer things and wipe
everything I'm gonna touch so that
includes inside of laboratory so
hopefully it's a little cleaner yeah by
with that although our immune systems
are crazy though because I've only
gotten sick like once I think it's I've
been exposed to every germ out there
pretty much next question what was the
interview process like okay well first
you gotta put your application
application in do a little research so
much airline you like yeah the base you
want cuz it's so much easier to live at
your base trying to control
shout out to all the people that commute
into base and then start work magining
have like some people complain about
like oh I have to drive an hour at work
imagine having to jump on an airplane
every time to get to work but the
interview process basically you got to
send in your application and they only
hire like once or twice a year depending
on the airline so you got to kind of be
on the lookout for that
updates and then you got a um they
usually do like a questionnaire just
kind of screening out all the crates of
people I guess you know make sure you
know how to personality answer like a
team are there things like that they
line up we having a flight attendant and
all these questions are like if you have
visible tattoos or if you're the right
age
yeah the questionnaire to be able to
sell alcohol you know and then step
three generally is a video so you answer
their questions
mm-hmm other airlines may do that a live
video well sir kind of like what we're
doing about that airline mm-hmm and then
step four you go in person yeah hi a
little boy name is and I want to
represent and I have this customer
service experience
choose me I've worked at and I'll give
you a call back and then from there you
get to go do training so that can be a
month that an interview process in
itself you're still being like you don't
automatically have the job when you go
to training you it's like a little bit
of bootcamp you know you basically still
Wheaton people out so if you don't wear
your pantyhose they want you you may be
going home but you just have to have
some grit and you're gonna be going
through some crazy drills and emergency
scenarios yeah gonna be able to do all
these exams and pass with at least a 90%
basically anything you know when you get
kicked out and put on the next flight
home your story
mmm-hmm bad bad it's really sad but yeah
you have to like be on top tip-top shape
cuz you're gonna be working overnights
and weekends and random mornings not
like just yeah I just celebrated
Thanksgiving and Christmas with my
family
last week so just prepared so I think we
doing that yeah because I knew I wasn't
gonna get it off so yeah that's I mean
yes
so I resent it though but um it depends
on the color on this beam in the plane
yeah you do hear a John look at that
color and it will tell you like for what
it means and one of our planes like the
orange is just somebody in the lavatory
I mean he'll but it looks like red and
that
like oh my gosh every time I'm like okay
okay wait it's just someone that tried a
flushed wedding but in blue is generally
the passenger someone yeah calling
usually look go ahead so you just look
at what row they're in thinking that
light you go down there yeah light
switch it's different then the one with
the little person on it that's for us
the one with the light switch is for the
light yeah people get it confused all
it's unusual needs bad what's the best
time of year to travel the best time
travel I would say when everybody else
isn't so summertime no winter no delays
delays delays in the summer do you got
thunderstorms in the winter you got snow
storms in the summer you got people off
of school in the winter you got holiday
vacation so these generally and depends
on the airline and Saturday so you can
actually look and to see like Sunday's
they sometimes have lesser flights
instead City or weekdays they have tons
of flights from true you know basically
Charlotte go someplace when everybody
else is it you know swim upstream
whatever one's going downstream yeah
yeah elebrate Thanksgiving a week early
yeah it's by then Kristi else's hours a
work do you wake do how many hours do
you work in a week well I feel like I
work 60 but I only get paid for six
months people don't know this but flight
attendants only get paid when the door
closes so when we're boarding and
planing wait am paid so we're working
for maybe like four hours but if the
flights only two cuz we gotta get there
and slowly gate yeah we gotta get there
early and we gotta watch you guys all
put your bags up oh hang your coats up
and all that stuff um and I was working
in a week so we're doing yeah it's very
good it's work like a hundred hours a
month like okay yeah weak berries cuz
you can pick your days off
you generally bit it and so some weeks
might be like none a couple yeah it's it
really varies like last week I didn't
work at all the hours and this week I
worked every day so your
indeed 75 hours most airline that's the
standard you get paid for 75 hours
minimum whether or not you work them or
not so yeah so big'uns cancel I'm sure
that on your schedule yeah hopefully a
pay protected okay Nikita love hey
Nikita what are your best trips for a
long-haul flight drinks water best tips
not trips oh you and your best tip yes
water moisturize moisturize we gotta
keep that looking baby fresh that
recycled beer does so much yeah you know
yeah you should so we understand like we
understand I would get one of those like
nail masks you know like the nail lady's
we're kinda like if people wear face
masks you know I mean I wish like we
could because they think it helpful it's
filtering the air but lemon in your
water does that help well you can ask
light in for lemon in your water I think
it helps I don't know protect okay yeah
yeah hydrate stuff yeah do a little
finger string snacks because I mean you
may bring earphone max yeah bring better
songs you're gonna get hungry and I know
you don't want to spend a bunch on the
snack box I mean it's there but yeah
just bring your earphones as courtesy to
everybody else bring a hoodie because it
always hold on planning meal too and you
can bring it as your carry-on
I've brought a cake before you know it's
like this is like cake from this place
in DC that really like so I was like
yeah I'm bringing this and they'll just
scan it you say we'll look at it alright
cool nothing release its my bit yeah let
me know let me try that again
and then eat that on the plane and
everyone would be envious of you I mean
hopefully you don't have something that
smells too crazy cuz I'm Asian so I get
the fishy smell and get back don't go
Ariana I know don't bring dirty you know
what that is don't bring be like
consider it like ask the person nice to
use okay that you say is like it's cool
I'm gonna start like I don't need it
yeah just Ana that helps so much I know
so many people that get so hungry and
all they have this like pretzels per se
for that day true then they are
miserable and they can't fall asleep
because they like are so hungry true
food yes
pita bail how much do you fight a 10
get paid or I shoot what my venmo is a
who rappers oh ha ha
okay tweet what how much do flies heaven
gets paid well back to that 75 hours
minimum we're gonna need an hourly pay
payment of 75 hours a month but it
varies it's over 800 yen on the airline
to also depends on seniority generally
around like the 20 something per hour
yeah and up yeah depending depending but
yeah every year it goes up every bonus a
dollar like a year 20 a year but if you
work a lot like if you work over that 75
hours so you're like overtime you could
definitely get more yeah and every year
it does accumulate but I make the most
of I get paid and well we also get free
snacks so we get paid airplane food all
the soda not as long as life benefits
those are the don't run guy says I
probably use my flight benefits if you
were to do the math probably more than
oh yes my paycheck I do this job I mean
come on
seriously those thousand dollar flights
and if you're you're someone that has
family all over the place it's perfect
because you can you can be there if your
cousin has a baby or like your grandma
falls down and it's her and she's like
all the way in Michigan or something
like normally I would just be like all
right hopping on the next slide gonna be
there ASAP yeah normally I would not go
home for a baby shower but I might I
will I might go I know a lot of bougie
flight attendants that will go shout-out
to you guys I love y'all y'all go to
Paris to go shopping yeah yeah Paris
your shopkin cuz you get some deals on
those on nice designer purses and bags
or they will go to their hair
appointment that's a like three hour
flight from LaGuardia to Houston and
evilly because they only trust that one
lady that's in Texas for their hair and
they only trust that one lady or male or
whoever for their nails in line said
cities
through God's they loyal alright here we
go do you think parents should travel
with newborn children don't sure get
them used to all those germs and build
up their immune system yeah give the
blankets I know lots of like babies that
fly yeah you got babies on your speed
dial all the time and they could be
brand new spanking babies like this baby
with birth like yeah like weeks ago yeah
but yeah I in the parents like as long
as the it just depends on the baby if
they can say third they're comfortable
if they say like wait what like four
months or something yeah baby might be
yeah if it's a cry baby I mean I
wouldn't waste like a cricket years the
Bahamas on your baby cuz they're not
gonna remember it and you're gonna have
more fun without the baby
but um grandma's not available doesn't
like fine you'll know you'll know and
just listen to you yeah I don't have any
babies god oh my gosh guys I'm really
good class I'll go in in that's being
cool um wait where did it go okay there
we go
cero Martin what's your scariest
experience on a plane Oh gayest huh um
generally if it's past moderate
turbulence for me um well there's this
one instance that I this lady screamed
like screamed and I was like whoa like
thinking like something had happened no
none of story sorry it just like
connects all these things but I had a
passenger recently had a seizure on my
flight and medical emergency knowledge
just kicks in you're like zoned in
that's the thing there was only a
gynecologist to help me hahaha and let
me check here well that's not gonna help
reflecting on everyone in the back yeah
we communicate with the captain in every
year but we did it just happened in
flight and so we had at least 40 minutes
left before
and it's one of those things that you
have to act instantly well okay the
thing is it's like I've also had a
seizure on my plane and there's really
nothing you can do you said a mere a
seizure way yeah you just don't give him
anything to drink I thought initially
that's - no don't put anything that or
the you know session yeah like was over
he like didn't remember anything that
happened but we did get medical
personnel to meet him he got taken to
the hospital after a letter saved the
day yay Sam T what would you recommend
for a first time Heinlein no we're nice
people yeah we'll probably give you HOT
to you with lemons yeah let them down
yeah ruber 21 might give you a glass of
wine let you snooze you know yeah and
get there early just like you know tom
agee window seat or whatever makes feel
collabo do you realize that train
yourself you probably have thousands of
hours and they're well skilled and
autopilot is great oh yeah these planes
for themselves perhaps
practica way there's nothing really to
be afraid of when you see unaccompanied
kids flying do you keep an eye on them
actually that's funny I had a first-time
girl on my plane it was her first time
flying and but she didn't speak any
English so we didn't know that it was
our first time flying and then we had
the worst turbulence ever poor girls
pregnant organ plated kid we liked it so
bad music oh well I would just you speak
and then it like language well let's and
I thought it was pretty decent until I
tried to communicate with a
fifteen-year-old and I'm like oh I think
I only have five year old Spanish I was
like Romero uno time on an aeroplane and
she was like yeah so but yeah we get we
practically are responsible for them
were their unofficial
we're watching you guidance counselor
Eve they're the last ones off the plane
because we're the ones escorting them to
the next person that's gonna watch them
generally the
yeah yeah I keep them take them to them
I'm a bit late the most fun flight
they're ever gonna hat look I'm like
what I'm all yes yeah like really like
you want cookies you want sure we got
showed us without understanding ever
party time
yes by triggered children
oh how funny don't miss the question a
clean our this aren't are the seats and
fresh hmm well uh I would just wipe it
down yeah I would just wipe the seat
down with your own raggin check it out
yeah very maybe while especially table
well the feel yes let's say the food is
not exactly farm-to-table so yeah right
yeah a might and then the plans what the
ovens will cook them make them nice to
meet you
I mean if you need organic gluten-free
vegan options only maybe bring your own
food but I can also most airlines let
you know like you can put it whenever
you're getting your ticket sometimes
like kosher bad people I give them the
coach for me on their life position
trapeze I don't want chickpeas yeah but
I was like this is their only because
your option sorry can make it nice and
bring some extra snacks
throw in some snacks chips in there hmm
um Reni Lynn what is the best way for me
to get bumped into first class I said it
once and I'll say it again if you want
to upgrade upgrade your life well I can
go to the gauge and say I want to
upgrade and then swipe your card and pay
the fee
yeah we can't really do much I mean but
I mean chocolate bring snacks we like
chocolate
thank you no kid yeah like pictures
maybe you never know maybe for weight
and balance if the plane is small enough
they might know that dearly you're on
the top of the list you need to move
some wine for weighing balance no no yo
mm-hmm okay here we go do you notice any
regulars why yes we do we have these um
that's yeah really especially with the
shuttle flights we're like we know just
a shuttle flight yeah are basically like
between LaGuardia and DC
it takes pretty much 30 minutes yeah
like it takes me longer to get to the
airport then to actually work the flight
and yeah a lot of those people they go
to work every day in DC but they live in
New York and so it's the same people
usually they have a meeting and then
they'll fly back the same day and
sometimes you might see the same person
or I've had it actually happen more than
once which is crazy but I'll fly to a
place and they'll be the Pastner and
then I'll stay the night and then the
morning flight I'll fly out don't be the
same person oh yeah I've had that too
and usually they recognize you because
we see a lot more of you than you see of
us but um just play it off cool Hey yeah
Tom look on your little shoes you're
seeing this you see like you know yeah
or you're like wait you guys somebody
know how it goes you know exactly
whenever we're supposed to tax you when
we're supposed to you know put the
seatbelts on put your seat up know that
we like regulars actually they know the
drunken selected tip intro club and
you're just like thank you but I can't
um do you have any advice for people
that want to become a flight attendant
well get over your fear flight Heights
because yeah I'm all the customer
service experience most of the airlines
that I know need at least two years it's
really nice to see it well-rounded we'll
have some sort of management fun don't
do drugs
because you will get drug tested that
are visible yeah that's true like if you
got a tattoo on your arm it happening
for you honey sorry yeah you can't have
anything you can try to hide it with a
band-aid or watch but they will find it
work out if you can't push a cart that's
over 250 pounds oh dear yes and be able
to lift push pull hmm all the things for
the door yeah I need to be able to hear
yes there's a couple other things I'll
tell you but there's be you have to be
really flexible because you could be
working at 2:00 a.m. on a Saturday night
or you could be working at 4:00 a.m. you
know and
during the holidays and for six days
straight or you could have yeah it's
crazy crazy schedule but if you like
change and for me at least like I didn't
like sitting in office all day like
shout out to everyone that do that like
a lot of work to I don't know how you
guys do it I could feel my body
deteriorating like just sitting posture
like yeah not so great feel like yeah
like yeah so I want our statements we'll
have your schedule will change every
single day
you don't know like there could be a
delay and then you think that you're
gonna stay in Texas but you're going to
the Bahamas all right you know but you
know some days you do get trips like
that and don't call you and they'll tell
you all right we need you to fly this
plate to this place and you're like okay
great
do I have a sweater my bag or do I have
a bathing suit I always a bathing suit
my bag always even and I'm like oh good
bein like put it out here during the
winter like change things can change you
listen to the voice in the sky and ATC
and all these things melt oh yeah crew
scheduling hello not yeah like I have
goggles in my bag because I'm a hardcore
hotel when a bullet swimming yeah every
single time I love neck pillow and I
know people like whenever yeah Leoni
have you ever been busy yes so yes there
you know I know but maybe I'm just like
intimidating like no no no I have never
been knock on wood
yeah um physically threatened yeah what
did they say to you mine was a passenger
that definitely drank before the flight
but never showed signs of it so like as
a flight time usually skåne everyone he
kind of know um just little things about
the person and this passenger was fine I
had served him a drink didn't have any
signs of being intoxicated and later on
the flight it was starting show I don't
have to sell to you but it was hit I'm
the more they know
he sexually assaulted another person in
first class she was a female and he was
a male and she was married and she was
definitely not asking for it
so I separated the two and he started
totally gonna go to sleep was he sitting
next to her knee she was sitting next to
ya and he just kind of I'm out this is
me I'm with first class honey you know
and then he started doing like once I
stopped read them he like was starting
to go to sleep so I was like monitoring
him but I put her back in near her in
near this other Florida Senate that was
non rubbing and then he started like
waking up again and was like gonna do it
to this other female passenger although
I'm also cry and I could tell that like
okay like he was slurring his words and
all he was saying was bourbon to me and
was like why don't you get like
basically babe like why don't you give
me my bourbon sighs I'm sorry but but I
can get you some water and he snacks
like please sit down like and then once
fast-forward to us
taxiing so he landed Kevin already knows
everything on the side Sena knows and he
keeps on getting out of his seat and he
keeps on unbuckling his seatbelt
and if we're taxiing I'm gonna say over
and over on the PA please come please
make sure your seatbelts are securely
fastened cuz we were an active tack even
though it's only one person you're
really talking to yes and you look at
them and they know well I don't know if
you knew but yeah we had to meet the so
he was definitely like doing the same
thing with me as cheers he didn't he
didn't get to that point I was I was
like what Lansdowne I know karate down
yeah but law enforcement met the
aircraft on sagessa gate so today was
handled it was handily there we go 14
team can you read this one I don't know
the mayan twins are goo how do you
handle noisy babies
I say hasta baby don't say a word Mama's
not gonna bring you some peanuts and
pretzels
I don't know sing
noisy baby you know what like there's
really nothing you can do is there
anything I do I am the pretzels if the
parents are cool with it so they can
play with it sometimes that's sometimes
because their babies are like what's
this and they're all I distract it for
like two seconds and they choke animate
nom like don't open the bag keep it
close yeah or hmm usually you just have
to write it out just gotta ride it out
yeah baby your headphones for other
parties yeah bring some earphones yeah
that's nice music I've seen that before
where ya knew it was their first flight
and they the parents brought everybody
around them earplugs and it's really you
know yeah that was a little snacks but I
mean go along where what my friend did
she just dressed her little baby up in a
pilots outfit and everybody was just too
amused by how cute he was they didn't
care if he cried so there you go yeah
yeah my baby cloud says has a bib ever
been delivered on a wings there has been
so many records and oh that have like
dual citizenship but personally I
haven't experienced that
no I've yeah but it has been done I
didn't hear about well the toilet baby
though anyway um okay have you ever
caught someone having it doing it having
the sex in the bathroom the sexy tile
the bathroom I've seen anybody join the
mile-high club but I they probably world
I get the hundred meter dash you know
like they were gonna do something like
they were sharing a blanket and I don't
even think they knew each other so I was
like what's going on here better like
making out and like you know like taking
like they're drinking and again to know
each other or if they're a couple like
yeah I've had one couple like before we
even took off like she was sitting on
his lap and like just like hugging a lot
bomb are you a message I know this was
not a lap child miss get our I am I'm
gonna put your seat bone on for safety I
don't want you fly it even though we're
not flying
um you know I people might be doing
stuff under blankets mm-hmm I know you
guys do it
we know yeah and we know whenever
someone walks out of the mockery please
offer you a hot amounted I'd like to
close of a time and they're little like
a roughed-up and stuff but oh one doing
like good I don't know I don't know
machen just don't do it in front of kids
and don't do it in front of like just
just save it those bathrooms are nasty
yeah yeah you gotta be really you get
suspicious but you I've never seen
someone just actively being I think I'd
be Jax on the plane so repulsed by all
the bacteria it was just not it was just
wouldn't happen yeah wouldn't do it for
me and then you feel like it handcuffed
off the plane and through the airport oh
yeah that's right - it isn't you're not
supposed to my good part of the role
play let's check out what else is going
on here thank you guys so much for
joining us by the way we love y'all love
y'all um has anyone ever vaped on a
plane jingo boy blue asked that oh yes I
did smell it smelled like cotton candy
and I know that nobody was eating cotton
candy I'm like I think someone's vaping
on this plane when was this recently
yeah it's kind of recently and it says
it so many times it announces omen me
yeah it's dangerous it's like you can't
you can't have that all my up there I
just said take that thing apart before
you're on the plane don't smoke it I'm
not saying you are doing this but if you
are just no you will be kicked off and
we will land this flight me I mean
nobody wants a delay my first month
applying so I was finishing a meal
flight so I was like putting all the
meals up and cleaned up everything me
and this other junior flight attendant
we're just like talking in the back and
because we had just finished service I'm
like great awesome easy flight landing
in ATL great so then we say
emergency light hop on and we get a call
from captain captain's like is there a
fire in the lab can you go check the
smoke day long so we take the door not
hot
open it nothing's in there but there's
like a smoke and it does smell it oh I
like inspect everything like other
flight attendants there with me and we
did see like a passenger like exiting
and he was sitting in first class and so
obviously didn't mind Tara kitchen ask
questions I needed to ask found out he
was vaping and then has it like about
$5,000 yes and we were about to land
anyway so we just landed at the normal
airport versus land and then yes it is
you can get that you can get really
worth it can you wait 30 minutes
absolutely yeah we have to report it
through so much paperwork so much
insulin reports oh and yeah you scared
everyone cuz there was someone sitting
in that one seat where you know me
sitting my jump seat I can see you right
there they're looking right at me she
was freaking out it was like its owner
lady and she was like what's going on
I'm scared so I went to comfort her and
everything it was like don't scare
everyone on the be scared don't be weird
a little old lady bad guys um let's see
what else we got yeah like the heart you
have a slaw well like that name - do you
actually get to see such explore the
destinations you fly - oh yeah I could
settle in Milwaukee there's a McDonald's
and they got a Wendy's it's really nice
oh no sometimes yes sometimes no
sometimes on how tired you are just
about just the length of the overnight
and the cost of the uber ride cuz a lot
of the times were right by the airport
that's where they put us not in the
actual city city they don't always give
us a car rental mmm please for us over
four hours if we have an overnight 24
hours we go to cars so it's like do what
I really want to pay the time for 23
hours well we want to pay $30 to go see
downtown Nebraska
Omaha or whatever live there though but
it's like you just got away your always
there's stuff you can always find stuff
to do that was true it is kind of cool
you get in cities that you would never
normally go to yes and you got to see
how like people live everyone's like
like a Monday and you're just like oh
everyone's just going on their thing and
you're like I'm being super tourists
today on every single Museum and I went
to the ketchup museum and this museum
yeah probably never would have seen the
most biggest eyeball or the biggest
Dallas random things like yeah yeah and
stuff yeah it's so it really depends I
mean sometimes you just see the hotel
breakfast that's all you see of that
city and then you don't remember though
you were actually in that city until
you're eating the breakfast and you're
like oh yeah I remember these potatoes
I've been here before and sometimes all
you see of a certain city is their
runway and you're like wow look at
Cancun nice okay gotta go dip in the bed
yes I really hate what he was Charlie
he's around you're next oh you know what
I feel because I can't hiding baller
it's party nerves I want you story
behind it but mm actually they're wet
night I feel I've been there's nothing
you like from their part of Drew yet the
tradition mostly I feel like y'all the
flight attendant you don't actually a
good question charlie I'm gonna look
into it they actually though yeah we
should know the history yeah the history
I don't know what it does tell you what
co-chair yeah well that's what it is
like so any easy way to be like hi this
is my brand
yeah like can't you tell we would I
represent my brand Asian baby girl
airline yes I don't know that's a good
question thanks Charlie we'll look into
it
yes what like a bang like a boy Chang
what is the best seat in economy are
there any emergency exit rows always a
good spot no friends actually I don't
like them really yeah leg room yeah
you're not for it oh you don't like that
response cuz they be like sometimes they
don't have room for their bags and
them oh well I guess there's like I'll
give that up for ya um I would say the
ones right behind all the first class I
mean I don't know that's council's
economy sometimes it does
I like mondo cuz I like to rest my head
yeah I am the window and then if you use
the bathroom a lot definitely aisle yeah
do you think do you ever want some
mm-hmm and if you like cuddling with
random strangers sit in the middle seat
that's what I always end up doing play
no secret is fun though have you ever
been in an emergency landing oh we don't
talk about those calculator tortilla
real fancy and loose till gosh oh yeah
let's get my heart bumpin read me how do
you like brace brace yeah yeah yeah
sometimes oh gosh yes and anytime we
watch a fight attendant movie or
airplane movie any of those with extreme
turbulence and things like that a lot of
it is dramatized I will say yeah but
yeah we kick into safety mode and we're
already like looking at who are
able-bodied passengers the people that
could actually lift up the door and help
people out and maybe carry that one
little like person that has like a
broken leg or something yeah you know
old people though yeah baby ones any
little help like if we have a like blind
passenger on board or like this
passenger and this this you already
already know it Charlie what I think it
is pretty yeah I'm in a tortilla yeah
yeah hope never know I hope never are
there perks for more senior flight
attendants absolutely it's all about
those in your flight attendants and
people call some some of them like the
female and senior Mama's thing your mama
send them live yeah I know it's all
about seniority in the flight attendant
world the more the more years you'll
follow you the whole time you're with
that airline hmm so you get a better
schedule
you get more pain I take what position
you want to work but you earned it you
know you've been there and you've been
there done that
yeah gone to all the recurrence hmm so
yeah there see the people come and go
and you're still there and you're
killing it you know what I see
where is all the food and stuff it's
cool thing yeah galley cards in there
usually all lined up cute and organized
everything has its own place and a lot
of times flight attendants have their
personal way they like to organize
things and make their little cubby cute
and where they like to put their
pretzels in there this part soda
compartment thing food kept in my belly
no yeah it's it's sometimes cooked it's
sometimes raw food sometimes you got to
cook it
sometimes on it's already they're gonna
be eating cold sometimes some like it's
almost cooking we do is pull off the
wrapper but yeah yeah yeah and then
we're like put on a pretty tray hmm
choice option one or choice option two
you know we have a little more like
vibrato I guess yeah we explain like
what it's like turkey sandwich or it's
um smoked turkey with Gouda on marbled
rye bread with that other lettuce and
sliced tomato magus or just like that
turkey sandwich really depends what mood
yeah
scarlet what's your favorite airline to
fly on the ones that give you extra
snacks in love and attendant and the
flight attendants are happy yeah they
don't look like they're overworked are
you tired
in the most seat room yeah and uh I do
like the Airbus a380s cuz the room and
the lavatory's are bigger just like yeah
sorry yeah and you don't feel turbulence
much on the air Pacific area I don't
think
No do you know which one yeah you don't
know once you don't got to pay extra for
your bag everything with the energy
Bremen you know all that stuff um but I
always cetera dot flogs with to what
three yeses has anyone ever asked you
out on the job yeah yeah it's usually
people I wouldn't go out with I wish it
why you look for that round finger
that's true yeah yeah that meant I'm
gonna disqualify yeah and um I'm nervous
I know daddy yeah but I know people have
definitely been like that girls yeah you
have you ever been out with anybody
passenger not been out but been asked
out oh okay
so so and I know lots of people that
hope this is like one joke that one of
my flight attendant friends said she did
to ask someone else out was like you're
looking like a snack here's one and gave
a flight attendant snack like one of
those like nicer snacks to the man yeah
and then I think they like hung out and
just had dinner coasters in the city but
um any sent the napkin back people had a
say well like if they if it's a long
enough fight maybe you'll get to know
them maybe when you're waiting to use
the laboratory even though you're not
supposed to be in the galley waiting
especially like wait for that light but
then they will spike up a conversation
and I've gotten a lot of you guys we're
drying and guys say hey if you ever need
any thing here's my business card and I
look down like we're gonna do the
medical sales rep like I'm not I don't
need that if you're ever back in said
said city and come in you know yeah give
me a call
mm-hmm specially like elder yeah the
older guy yeah
and you're like
have a nice day and then probably never
see them so it's okay there should be a
dating app for people on the plane yeah
because this is kinda hard to so dating
as a flights in it kind of hard because
of the schedule but you can make it work
so this is another one thing that's so
many people whenever I was dating around
like you know just being single and
enjoying life mhm
people would always assume that flight
attendants didn't have real
relationships that they're in
relationships all the time probably fine
if you're into that like but also you
can also have a committed monogamous
relationship you can make your schedule
work around that person schedule you can
be a lot more flexible and you think and
then if you guys are super serious you
can put them on your benefits you talk
about and do your honeymoon vibe that
year long probably the main reason my
long-distance relationship is working
and he's on my flight benefits otherwise
it'd be like next year sorry
a lot of science will not tell you
you're there a flight attendant cuz they
don't want you to mooch off them because
number one thing people like to do is
like oh do you have any extra buddy
passes and it's like I haven't seen you
since elementary yeah well like you were
in one of my like classes I don't
remember who are you what's your love
again no it's always random people from
your past that ask you for buddy
batteries I'm like my aunt my best
friend hasn't even asked for my buddy
pass and you want one because I'm like
what I did don't only I'm gonna put my
mom dad significant other siblings
cousins like it's gonna have a line yeah
you're not even number 10 you're not
even top 10 and you think you're gonna
be a mom back it's always that team
enrollment comes to when people know
like it's time for you to change your
list man was a car I get it though I get
it like that's the per gallon job and
it'd be so fun if we could put everyone
on it
free flights off for me yeah great
ultimate gamer ass if the plane is about
to crash what do passengers have to do
pray pray every prayer you've ever
prayed in your life do you believe in
yeah we even sit down okay really fast
turbulent grab whatever is near you
that's stuck so like the armrest the
chair like anything to seat yourself the
other passenger just grab something yeah
put your seat belt on hmm its doctrine
mass falls put yours on then help others
just follow your flight attendant goals
read the safety information guard
position gosh does anybody read that
thing put your hands everyone pay
attention to the safety of your legs and
depending on what type of aircraft or
you can put your hands like show my
brace position yeah there you see in
like over you know you know and just so
baby you are when the baby's gonna less
lessen the crash yeah yeah but mostly
job we usually do the brace position and
then we're like either leaning back yeah
we're depending on where we're sitting
at what flavors chest I'll forgive
yourself for anything that you've ever
done in your life and hope for the best
yeah repent of all my sins
yeah repentance um what kind of
passenger is the most annoying the one
that plays their music with no
headphones loud falls asleep and the
music is still going and everyone's like
and it's a morning flying everyone's
trying go sleep that sounds so personal
because they like that happens it was
like everyone's trying to sleep on a
plane like I'm getting so many
complaints please can you turn down your
rap music which I love but like not at
like 6:00 in the morning and then you
wake up that baby that like vonlee fell
asleep you know right and yeah I would
just say people who be wanting all this
first-class service when they're the
back of the plane like they want their
pre-departure beverage they want a
blanket they want all this extra stuff
headphones oh Allah and it's like yeah
you get all that for ya up there but
dang like I was like or the short
flights that are like 30 minutes and you
have to do beverage service and you have
someone that like the first person
you're giving beverage to is already
asking for five things
and I'm like I gotta get to rest the
plane and we're about to land so I gotta
be this quick so please don't ask for
like three different drinks and for me
to make some special like sunset
clearness mimosa crazy like three drinks
for you before I get through with the
service like maybe I'll never finish
everybody didn't ask for another one
press your call button it's fine yeah or
people who just like ask for things that
I don't think they've ever been on a
plane before
do you have chocolate milk or lemonade
or orange pop no this is not a grade
school cafeteria we don't have any of
that
sorry also in the back of the magazines
that we usually have they will tell you
what type of drinks we have everyone go
yes that they tell you the type of
drinks all of them by brand everything
so you don't have to ask so what do you
have and we go through this giant list
and then you ask for water yeah oh my
gosh I know so many flight attendants
per raised like hey they stress like
don't ask what I know it's like okay we
appreciate you wearing headphones when
you're watching the video but when we
come to our service take them off like
you know so I have people that keep them
on Pete Mara maybe a whole pod asking
you like I'm I'm clearly here because
okay here we go Laura
Jin Chen che Jan Chi Jane Street flora
Jane see any advice for people who get
motion sick oh I think they got ain't no
doctor but I think they got medicine for
that yeah and oh just uh warm water with
lemon that's like you're gonna brief and
we're limited with the resources there
are little bags there yeah early yeah
motion sickness just stay seated a lot
of times if you're on your phone a lot
to you I know that that bothers people
sometimes with the motion sickness it
could depend on the person yeah but you
know you're watching a lot of videos and
your wheat or yeah sometimes even
reading like trying to focus on this and
then like if there's a lot of turbulence
that's just messing with your focus you
just go to sleep try to go sleep we'll
give you a blanket pick some sleeping Oh
every twenty-one drink glass of wine
Julieta my cornmeal and Neela Alice oh
hey miss Corning's shoutout to you are
you are you friends with the pilot so
there let me work with we actually I
mean I've flown with a lot of the same
pilots which not everyone can say but it
does happen and there are a lot of them
that I can just be like hey what's up so
and so you know yeah and I will pass
each other in the airport yeah I mean
yeah we're friends with the Posche as
much as we are friends with the fly it
sounds like it's everybody like travel
with each other yeah if you want but I
mean a lot of the times it is the first
time you're working with these people on
a trip like you don't always work with
the same crew and it's kind of like
speed dating every single time you work
trip so where are you from what do you
do for fun okay great nice to meet you
bye then what can become family that's
true yeah sitting in the crew room
sitting hot and therefore for like eight
hours and then we decided to take a trip
to Greece together yeah after I saw
there for like less than a day and then
loved it no look at all I know we both
like cilantro yeah cilantro and we
packed light yes and what else do we do
hmm we'd be like Asian food are you we
don't drug agree really took us like 20
times to say hello yeah but what is it
again do you remember
honest topical okay I speak Vietnamese
girl and English oh okay um-hmm it's
going so fast I know right Jen Jen yes
what would you do if you caught someone
having sex in the airplane
let's defense offer them a warm towel Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
feels like in the middle of them like
doing it and it was like in this to eat
I gotta I gotta say something okay I'm
just dad I couldn't do you choose the
flight you want to go on or do you get
assigned fast CX science well if I could
choose I would be not choosing to go to
Rochester I'd be going to Rome no you
don't only get to choose you can bid you
can bid so put your preference
preference but and I know some people
that are very senior looking for their
preference to Jamaica and Bahamas and
all these fun fun places and they can
add a whole month
just those overnights because they're so
senior so nice but if you're not yeah
but if you're not you don't even bother
you're going they're going to Louisville
whether you like it or not for the 20th
time no fun I think I've been Lou I love
Louisville or I have times in one month
yeah I don't understand like it was just
like they just decided yeah yeah right
Rochester yeah yeah but I got like a
Jacksonville coming up Manuel Manuel
palmares says has anyone pooped their
baby yes okay just babe how did you guys
know they like asking bands like they
already know me yeah
this happened before I mean I change the
babies didn't happen to me person yeah
either babies are old being usually they
change in the laboratory and like well
did it happen to me personally but I did
hear another flight tenant co-worker
tell me she had somebody bringing their
own squatty potty once a grown person
and just post up in the galley and just
do the deed and
that's not okay
yes I think they had to land clay in the
plane Emily Emily s do you have a
permanent house less apartment or is it
always hospitals so many different
answers for this it really depends yeah
three I didn't have yeah I was like my
my three homes were my friend like Rosie
my friend cast Lee my friend Regina
those were my home oh I could commute -
yeah so my home is a pol is my parents
house yeah no but now we're blessed we
have a real apartment but yeah sometimes
we're gonna wait you're like wait why do
I have one I'm in hotels half the month
but yeah usually you're in the hotel
like seriously half the month and then
some other people they'll stay out of
place and they'll pay like a daily rate
yeah they have no food called crash pads
as well yeah
and so they'll just stay there for like
eight hours before their flight
so they'll flying in a permanent address
it's like not where they're based yeah
crash pads are essentially like
someplace you need to crash or you kind
of live there and it's like 12 people in
bunk beds in one room it's basically
like summer camp but without the fun and
adults yeah so like it could be guys
girls depending on which type of crash
pad yeah they could become me sometime
yeah but all good if you're used to
being on the go shout out to our roomie
and saving us from the crash pad some
airlines do give you extra hotel room
yeah if you are needing uh-huh yeah well
it's nice to have a place that you can
have as your own bed that's not a hotel
bed sometimes true you need that like
Zen peaceful time to just like get back
get rid of the jetlag all that mm-hmm
true - from Pratt because our provocated
Lowen Buckingham asked has anyone ever
tried to open the door during flight
well which door cuz I've had people open
the lab door someone else was so
entertaining the
cockpit tour thankfully no and the
emergency door well good luck cuz it's
impossible to open it it's like you'd
have to have extreme strength if your
india like that one scene in Charlie's
Angels when they open the emergency go
impossible for an angel but ya know it's
impossible the pressure too much because
people are like why don't you have
parachutes if the plane goes well how
are we gonna open the door you tell me
how are we gonna do this and then we do
you see someone heading for the cockpit
door we have policies and procedures to
stop stopping it no one's allowed not
like back in the day where you'd like
having kids stuff to him like look at
the cool lights and things in the
cockpit and all the buttons no you can't
do that in flight maybe you can do that
on the ground if we're already landed
and you open the door and you ask the
captain he's cool with it I'm gonna kid
up they're all the buttons opening that
door unless I need to use a restroom or
Kareem Dawood says do you get a bed on
the plane well no we sleep in the
overhead bin so you never notice that
you never open your overhead bin and
sometimes if they're long or not they're
big enough they do have these little
fine things where you can hardly bunkers
or that I've been in it can be lying
high taking my nap and then switching ya
pilots do that if there's like more than
two it could be like three pilots and
their knee rotates like for the longer
flights let them sleep but um no they
actually let us off the plane and go to
hotels so know that if it's the short
enough light we go into a real pen
because we're are real girls okay how
does one get my blanket the wide cup a
BYOB you bring your own blanket ask the
vice and appreciate you but usually they
just make enough for business class and
if it's cold
well yeah yeah fine a lady in fourteen
see who's knitting and you ask her to
make you one that's you
doing those Airman's like brisket cat
ass do you get a cat man a sheen do I
get scared of crashing all the time
every day Coffman landing no I become so
routine yeah all of the things that we
do yeah kind of forget that we're like
in the air you know yeah we're just
gonna like haha walking through my like
doing my thing doing my job
that we don't like you get that wake-up
call when something does happen I mean
you do review it yeah every time do you
like turbulence like are you one of
those flight times that likes turbulence
I mean it doesn't bother me as it did
before
yeah yeah so like now I'm kind of just
like like I know what I can handle and I
know like whenever it's starting to get
really rough mm-hmm
whenever you can tell the types of
turbulence but yeah I think the best way
to handle turbulence is to like remember
the rough ride or just anthem like stop
drop shut them down open up that's how
Rough Riders roll yeah you know that's
actually good advice like you know stop
what you're doing and sit down
Navaro just tipping a flight attendant
cash effect amount of feets of snacks
thank you
I mean depends what kind of flights in
it they are hey
generally um no but that's all Italy
correct dancers you know but usually
people tip at the end of the flight too
so it doesn't really you know but I mean
doesn't hurt we'll take your tip so much
fun okay
that was like yeah sending all this
questions okay awesome we got our last
question am i you're on roll please how
often are planes clean okay
mm that varies it depends how long in
between yacht I would like to say every
time thoroughly by 50 people they are
vacuum look usually after like they're
vacuumed and then the toilet seat is
piped and the sink is where and they
spray some stuff yeah and then spray
spray Triton and then don't ya strain
see yo let's pick up big trash you know
but no like and they look like some some
basis they look behind every single seat
pocket yeah that it looks like they're
all the trash but people have definitely
seen no like so probably not as often as
you would like but um they are clean
pretty much if there's a long layover
they do a pretty acceptable job so yeah
guys that's all for you my name is Suraj
you can find me down there for about two
yeah give them your Instagram name I
guess it'd be ha
and my name is uh who Rothfuss oorah
that's H double O are a number 4 surah
represented all of our flight attendant
friends and communities and Airlines
yeah guys so much fun thank you again so
now we get asked a lot of these
questions everybody for knows yeah able
to talk about it and just hanging out
with get more people informed ABG
Airlines signing out and be nice to your
fighters n it'd be nice to us because
we're just there to send love seriously
just say thank you like and sincerely
mean it it means so much compliments go
pretty far when you've had a long day
coming ya know just be like oh I like
your lipstick it's been fun Thank You
BuzzFeed yeah bye guys
you